this morning there is of a new push for
investigations after a scathing grand
jury report detailed alleged sex abuse
by more than 300 Catholic priests in
Pennsylvania
the Vatican Vatican broke its silence
yesterday and called for abusers and
enablers to be held accountable
adding the church must learn hard
lessons from its past
Nicky batiste is following this
developing story Nicky good morning good
morning the US Conference of Catholic
Bishops has proposed a new system for
reporting abuse but some survivors are
demanding more action they're greeting
the Vatican's response with skepticism
because they say they've heard the same
rhetoric before clearly the Holy See
condemns sexual abuse of minors people
spokesman Greg Burke insisted Pope
Francis was firmly on the side of
survivors it was in response to
accusations the highest levels of the
Catholic Church concealed and enabled
301 predator priests in Pennsylvania we
can express our feelings about these
horrible crimes in two words those are
shame and sorrow Shaun Doherty was just
10 years old when his family priest
began abusing him he and other survivors
were on the stage Tuesday when
Pennsylvania Attorney General Josh
Shapiro released a sweeping grand jury
report into sex abuses in the Catholic
Church what's everyone's reaction yeah
rage anger disgust it's just more of the
same the Pope is not on my side snap a
group of abuse survivors asked the US
Justice Department to open a nationwide
investigation similar reviews have
already taken place in Ireland and
Australia yesterday the attorneys
general of New York and New Jersey
indicated they may launch investigations
in their states the sheer scale of the
issue in Pennsylvania was really
couldn't have been worse theology
professor Candida Maas believes the same
horrific abuses and cover-ups found in
Pennsylvania likely exist elsewhere
an intelligent bishop he wanted to get
ahead of this problem would volunteer
his archives to avoid this fallout of
what happened in Pennsylvania
the Archdiocese of Newark New Jersey
tells CBS this morning it is auditing
its files on abusive priests and will
determine a protocol for any name
release once that review is complete
Cardinal Theodore McCarrick who recently
was accused of abusing seminarians and
altar boys was Newark's Archbishop for
14 years
Nicky batiste thank you very much